foreign
and I wish I can continue in in my
language so that I can make no mistakes
I greet you in the language of my
indigenous ancestors
and I acknowledge that I am that I am in
the homelands of the Lenape people
I am Jing and I come from the central
mountain range of the northern part of
the Philippines
if you've heard of The banaue Rice
Terraces which is one of the wonders of
the modern world that is the region
where I am from
my ancestors built these Terraces by
hand as a community Through the
centuries
it is their intimate knowledge
of Nature and of the way that the river
flows the waters flow and the waters are
stored that enables these Terraces to be
irrigated without the help of machines
the Art and Science of building and
irrigating these Terraces is magical
they have been sustainably and
beautifully irrigated for centuries
now my people are also known
as one of the unconquered and
uncolonized tribes of the Cordillera
mountains
we successfully resisted more than 300
years of Spanish colonization
because the mountains that we nurtured
and cared for protected Us in return
now to be sure the Spanish attempted
they heard about our gold so they sent
many Expeditions into the mountains to
mine our gold and to tax us
but the historical records show I kid
you not
members of the Expedition were sent back
inevitably
and sometimes without their heads
that's right
we are
we were a head-hunting people
and the name of my mother's Hometown
busao comes from the word buso which
means headhunter and this is why I'm
always joking around with my colleagues
I am a recovering headhunter
when we drove
Spanish out of the Philippines in the
late 1800s
they were unfortunately replaced by a
more creative colonizer
The Americans
and the pressure on our homelands
increased exponentially they wanted to
mine our goal to Dam our rivers and to
log our forests that we had cared for
at the risk of our own lives
when they wanted to damn the chico river
which is the lifeblood of the mountains
where I'm from
they were met with Fierce resistance and
protests from the people
our Braille grounds sacred places and
amazing Terraces would have been drowned
and lost forever and this was simply a
spiritual and cultural prize that my
people were not willing to pay
this project was funded by the World
Bank
and because of the fierce resistance of
indigenous peoples they were forced to
back off in the 1980s
and to put in place an indigenous
people's Safeguard policy to make sure
that development aggression doesn't
happen again in indigenous territories
without consent
okay so that's a new word and a big word
don't worry I'll explain it so what is
development aggression well development
development is um physical or economic
infrastructure that's put in place in a
community to help them Thrive and to
reach their goals like for example if
there is not enough affordable housing
in a community or inadequate access to
culturally appropriate education
development would build affordable
houses and enable access to culturally
appropriate education
simple but development aggression is the
opposite
it is development that exploits the
resources of the community and not for
the purpose of helping the community but
for the developers gain
hey
it is a manifestation of colonialism
and it it is a very Colonial world view
and comes from top-down decision making
as indigenous peoples we perceive it as
projects imposed without the consent of
the community and in a manner that
violates our rights
it falls in within the paradigm
of overproduction over consumption and
accumulation of wealth by individuals
which has proven to be not helpful at
all for Humanity and for the planet
foreign
I really think about you know why did my
ancestors why did my my forebears resist
the dam so strongly usually at the cost
of their own lives
you know the mountains are vast and we
could have moved away from the inundated
areas we could have gone to a different
place that was not poisoned by the mines
or that was not denuded by the logging
but my people explain that the struggle
against the dams The Mining and the
logging is a struggle for our identity
and for our cultural survival
it is a struggle to make sure that we
have healthy territories to pass on to
the Future generations and this is what
I've discovered through all my travels
and interactions with other indigenous
peoples this is common among indigenous
peoples worldwide the notion that we
hold our lands our Waters our
territories and our resources not just
for ourselves but for the future
Generations
or a peace pact holder he famously said
to the government bureaucrats who came
to the territory to push the dam
you ask us if we own the land and mock
Us by asking where is your title
when we ask the meaning of your words
you taunt Us by saying
where are the documents to prove your
ownership
titles documents proof of ownership
such arrogance
to think that you can own the land when
we are instead owned by it
how can you own something that will
outlive you
only the people own the land because
it's the people that live forever
as indigenous peoples we own our past
our present and our future
private development for the gain of the
few and to the detriment of the
community
flies against the face of the reality of
the generational existence of indigenous
peoples
so development aggression is actually a
an extension of a version of capitalism
that pushes over consumption over
production
and pass no regard for the future
Generations it's always more is better
extract as much value and labor as you
can from the land and from the people
without caring for the future
so when I was younger
story time
I grew up with my grandparents and they
always told me
eat everything in your plate I'm sure
you've heard that as well
but there's a deeper undercurrent there
eat everything on your plate in order to
honor the hands that planted nurtured
harvested and cooked the food
he taught me about the concept of inayan
or do not do anything that might harm
others or things that are bad evil taboo
or unethical so getting more than what
you need deprives others getting more
food than what you can eat
deprives the hungry and dishonors those
that produced it
he would ask me
when he sees uneaten rice on my plate
don't you hear the rice crying
and I would hear it crying so until this
day I can't leave rice on my plate
because I always hear the cries of the
rice
another concept that my relatives taught
me is
literally spread the good
spread the good values the good virtues
practices even material things
another way of saying it in my language
is
it means no one person should own what
is good it is to be shared with the
community it is an expression of
reciprocity
and honor for the collective and it
teaches us to care for the common good
so these values
reciprocity
spirituality
not taking more than you need
obligation to Future generations and
collective decision making all of these
values are now finding their way into
scientific studies and Global scientific
assessments on the status of
biodiversity and ecosystem services
climate change and land degradation
so what we all need to do now is what
indigenous peoples have always known and
have always done
as we face the negative effects of
biodiversity loss climate change extreme
weather events like the flooding the
wildfires the droughts
the scientists they are slowly moving
towards the conclusion that it is only
through indigenous wisdom and values and
ways of caring for territory that we see
the path towards our salvation
the path
towards our Salvation is not through
more development it's not through more
consumption or more production
over consumption development aggression
overproduction are all manifestations of
destructive colonialism that has harmed
the planet and that has undermined the
indigenous wisdom that the scientists
acknowledge that we all need
so
think about it
in spite of everything all the
challenges we have faced more than 500
years of colonization all of the
development aggression we are still here
indigenous peoples and our values have
thrived and have endured we have
survived and the least we can do is to
honor this resistance by decolonizing
our structures decolonizing the way we
think decolonizing our practices so that
we can stop the destruction of the
planet
colonization and its tentacles has
always deprived people and planet of the
things that we naturally and rightfully
need it is only by decolonizing our
understanding of history that we will
understand how we have arrived at this
planetary crisis
and it is only through honoring
indigenous peoples and being inspired by
the values
providing the support
and the resources in order for
indigenous peoples to continue to resist
development aggression and colonialism
that we can save ourselves and save the
planet
so I invite us
let's listen
Let's Be Inspired let us learn
and let us support the struggles of
indigenous peoples this is the only path
forward
thank you